what's up beautiful folks welcome to
another episode of get close I am Geo
and I'm Bart and I just want to say that
I love you so much you were just talking
[ __ ] to me right before we wrote do you
want me to put in this [ __ ] Clips I
was like hey you know what babe you made
a really great lunch yeah tell me
something I don't know
I'm great at cooking everyone knows that
who's everyone bro nobody in the whole
world like people just watching they go
oh [ __ ] that guy knows what he's doing
yeah and then I was like you don't even
match
yeah I wanted to ask you um
why I married you I have no [ __ ] clue
I asked myself that and that I never
want to know the answer to because I'm
gonna keep this trick for as long as
possible but um uh what were you
insecure about everything as a kid
and then what are you insecure about now
and did it change at all uh what's kid
what age group are we talking about
um let's say when you first like when
your titties started growing a little
bit [ __ ] okay well that's kind of [ __ ]
up because I have fake titties so they
never grew in a little bit
because you know I stuffed my bra you
did so that's an insecurity yeah because
I wanted titties how old are you and why
um I used to stuff my crotch too but I
was in I get it I was maybe in junior
high
the junior high yeah was it because
there's like chicks around that are like
I don't know maybe it was like social
like like the the media like marketing
social magazines yeah yeah
I was gonna say that so no but like just
scrolling on magazine or hey yeah the
old school scrolling yeah yeah I think
it was like the beauty standards of back
then too yeah
um but I mean who knows right like
because you are a product of your
environment so I don't know at what
point I got really influenced but even
before I even knew about titties and
puberty and all that [ __ ] like maybe it
was even the Barbies that I played with
but I don't know what influenced it
um but I remember I was very feminine I
was very much attracted to very feminine
items like makeup like high heels as far
back as I can remember like I wanted
nails so bad like um and I'm talking
about like maybe I was like five seven
around that age that like I always had a
piece of gum in my mouth I was [ __ ]
Violet I think her name is in Willy
Wonka the girl that always has gum in
her mouth you ever watched it okay cool
awesome
um great reference who's the Violet
equivalent in Bloodsport they're not
gonna relate better never mind okay oh
smooshy but yeah she always had gum in
her mouth and my gum I would take it out
and then I would like mold fake nails on
my hands or I would get like toothpaste
and pistachio shells yeah and then put
it on like I was always very into
feminine like dressing up I guess oh I
see
um so yeah I guess I guess around that
time you start liking boys now you want
a boyfriend and a girlfriend and you see
your friends getting boyfriends and
girlfriends and I wanted to dress a
little bit more less like a kid and more
like a woman
and then um yeah some of these chicks
were already developing boobs and I'm
like [ __ ] I want boobs and then they
would make fun of you if you didn't have
boobs but then they would make fun of
you if you did have boobs like such a
junior high is so [ __ ] weird I
remember there was two chicks
in my class
in sixth grade
that had boobs how big
I mean from a
from like a 11 year old they were
ginormous how big
I don't know your memory just whatever
you would like like this from the
perspective of this tall well I mean how
much taller are they than you aren't
they are they your teachers
what do you mean are they your peers or
your teachers they're my [ __ ] peers
all right no [ __ ] then aren't they both
the [ __ ] same ones why are you trying
to intimidate me for because I'm like yo
[ __ ] [ __ ] explain whoa cause
I was gonna say this I was gonna say
they're like a handful but that's weird
because these are adult hands yeah yeah
yeah well now if I put adult hands
that's the equivalent on uh kid boobs no
dude and then it goes down so I'm like
why are you trying to like that's it why
are you trying to incriminate why are
you trying to put adult hands on you
know what's cute what that you think you
grew that much from that age to now like
shut the [ __ ] up please you're like a
baby when I was
in sixth grade yeah you're like what
probably like 70 pounds four one
okay [ __ ] five six right now chill
out bro so yeah
um
like everyone in class was like oh did
you look at Becky yeah okay fine well I
don't know if people knew that I stuffed
my bra I never got called out on it
thank you
thank you big guy because Falconi that
would have been so bad every day every
day and I was so stupid I would use
cotton swabs usually gets like all hot
and sweaty in there and no but it was
like why did you even wear a bra if you
don't even have titties well because I
had like little bumps you know like it's
not like super flat like type of chest
right now oh yeah yeah you know we go
from Tiger chest to like even little
[ __ ] mosquito bites oh yeah even that
makes a significant difference yeah yeah
and then even that is kind of like
distressed a little bit yes yeah exactly
yeah I see so that's why so then uh yeah
I would use cotton balls and it was
funny because it was like slightly lumpy
so I couldn't really wear two like if I
wore this I wonder what the teachers
thought like especially the female
teachers I wonder they're like well oh
my god look how many cars so this is so
I think I was like pretty Advanced and
like my prepping of the [ __ ]
deceiving that I was doing yeah
because like I knew there were such
things as like underwire bras and like
cup like the the cupped bras or whatever
and I knew that some of them had lace so
like you could see some of the laser
pattern like through the material of the
shirt so I never really thought that you
could even really know or tell that it
was cotton because I'm like everyone
uses tissue like that's the Trope right
that's also dumb because it's just flat
uh well it's kind of bumpy but you can't
really mold it like it's not a moldable
thing so I would specifically buy the
jumbo cotton swabs and then I would just
kind of like open it up a little bit and
then I would get some smaller ones so
like I would just really mold it I would
have gotten water balloons and just
filled it up with like shampoo or gel
yeah that's why that's done it would
never work why that then it's actually
squishier and has a rounder shape okay
let's try that now we'll go get a bra
yeah and then we'll get some water
balloons and we'll see how that works
out yeah put gel and shampoos with the
thick viscous substance and I tie it and
I put it on does this make no that makes
perfect sense that's literally what you
have under your skin right now yeah but
it's in my skin it's not going anywhere
you're you're running the risk of it
falling out and now my balls are gonna
fall out not really I never had anything
any
a cotton ball it's one cotton ball yeah
and you can play it the [ __ ] off how do
you play out okay play off a cotton ball
your foot or playing [ __ ] something
and then one cotton ball Falls yeah are
you gonna think I'm stuffing my bra with
it no you're gonna be stuffing your bra
with cotton balls no one would ever
suspect it'd be like whoa that's weird
how come there's a combo I don't know it
got stuck on Me Maybe laundry or static
laundry cotton buds who knows it's a
school setting there's a bunch of school
projects static all of a sudden it goes
inside I was prepared to [ __ ] it's
not mine it came off of you you saw it
come out of me you and I are better you
would have a better chance stuffing your
bra with joints then if a joint falls
out oh yeah my bad well there is no
better chance because I got away with it
so it was the [ __ ] best chance no one
ever called me out on it except for my
dad one time see he knew but not that it
was cotton balls he was just like wait a
minute when did you get boobs like it
was so embarrassing he's like because he
really didn't like talk directly to me
never a dad and run into your room yeah
he was like wait what's going on here he
went like that and I was like he's like
when did you get boobs and then he
always called my mom by her first name
you know she's like he's like Martha
what the hell's going on when did she
get boobs and I was like oh my God I'm
about to get called out so I went back
into my room he just walked away I was
like Dad
yeah that was the only time I ever
thought I don't have a daughter right
now I know right those are some tough
talks props to all the dads out there
that got daughters
that never have those conversations just
leave it up to the mom yeah those are
tough talks yeah I [ __ ] stuffed my
bra dude
and I and I think cotton probably fell
out maybe in like how many did I do it
for a year I don't even remember how
long I did it for and I don't even
remember when I stopped I can't believe
we're just out here wasting cotton like
that hey I don't know you got to do what
you got to do when you're [ __ ] super
insecure so that's a big insecurity of
mine I wanted boobs so bad and I don't
even know why
at that age I don't know why I cared so
much maybe I just was like please boys
can you like me
was that your first insecurity
um no I wanted to shave my legs so bad
so everything was like more aesthetic
based as a kid yeah what else do you
know I don't know yeah I mean it seems
more like um not aesthetic Bass But like
yeah like aesthetic Woman based yeah I
mean you're it's your raging hormones
aren't all kids like that like you don't
want for me my first like the first
insecurity that I can think back to
has got to be no not five
um not six
yeah seven so when I was around seven
around that age I think I started to
have a a sense of self
and do I belong
because I think when you're like uh like
younger like five and younger you're
just you're just in the world
going crazy wearing whatever the hell
your mom or or dad wants you yeah you
just want you just wear whatever they
buy you you don't really quite know what
brands are like you know like you could
you might as well wear Gucci or Payless
and or Walmart doesn't really matter
you're just out here in the sandbox just
doing [ __ ] right uh haircuts whatever
your parents want but I think like maybe
when I was around seven that's when all
the kids on our street kind of had a
little bit more Independence
you know so it's not so much like
parents world it's more like kids world
like you're entering into kid kid land
and then when you go into kid land and
you see like a guy pull up on a bike and
another guy pulls up on a bike oh cool
is that GT yeah this is a GT what is
that oh that's a dino oh cool
what kind of bike is that and I'm like
silver
you know and it's like
I never heard of that one before
I'm like Oh my mom got at Toys R Us she
bought a bike at Toys R Us that's not
where you get cool bikes uh Bart has
whatever bye bartender bar yeah I'm like
the stupid bike you know and then that's
when I started realizing like oh [ __ ]
like man I want the stuff that everyone
else has and then you go to people's
houses and then you know you got you got
Nintendo Sega Genesis and they come to
your house like what's that I'm like
sense I got it I got I got this Chinese
Nintendo from Taiwan they're like what
what is this
and yet [ __ ] it's probably way better
than the American one it is because in
one cartridge had like 50 games yeah
that's tight but it's not their thing
right so it's not cool so that was like
my first insecurity where I'm like man I
just want to belong I just want to do
like
the the the stuff that everyone else
does you know I'm like we'll eat like
Lunchables right and then my mom's like
that's their lunch that's not even like
real food I don't care I wanna eat
yeah the processed meat yeah that's as
early as I can remember but no no that
was like Aesthetics you know it was more
of like uh belonging yeah do I have my
tribe that I belong with them yeah you
know
um did I have that I'm sure I had that
somewhere I'm sure or is it maybe
a uh I don't have a siblings thing so
that was like extra maybe or maybe
people experienced that way younger but
if they fit with their older sibling
when they're five they're like okay well
at least I have one tribe uh I don't
know because like my siblings were so
much older than me like my brother's 10
years older my sister's 15 years older
so it's not like I grew up with other
kids you know
um
obviously you're gonna get picked on if
you are different or if you have
different things and the popular kids
for sure I think that's we all went
through that like I remember I wanted so
when I was growing up
um in elementary school LA Gear remember
LA Gear that was the [ __ ] like everyone
wanted L.A gears
you [ __ ] didn't you did I only
remember what the shoe looks like
anymore but I just remember LA Gear
because this is like a core memory now
because I was so [ __ ] disappointed so
I remember asking Santa and now it
breaks my heart because I know my mom's
situation but anyway
um guess how many times I got to wear
them though
[Laughter]
honestly probably under 10 times oh
that's not bad I wanted some sick sick
ones and uh they were one of the ones
with like they had like these like this
cool design on the side or it's like
black on one side and blue on the other
and I thought they were sick and those
are the ones I wanted
and then my aunt who was going to fit
him at the time you know she's into
fashion and all that stuff so she heard
I want those she goes I know exactly
what those are so I think for a birthday
or Christmas she bought them for me
won't go with the release of school
they're wearing Payless the whole time
you know finally some name brand [ __ ]
and my mom was like oh those are nice oh
you can't wear those and then put them
away I never understood what I
understand but I also don't understand
why parents do that like yes when you're
poor you try to make it last because
you're trying not to appear poor yeah I
get it but the rate that children
[ __ ] grow yeah from literally like
less than half a year they're not
fitting that [ __ ] anymore I know so you
[ __ ] stored it for a rainy day it
only rained one time and now the kid
doesn't fit anymore so you don't even
get your money's worth and they're
sneakers they're meant to be worn and
beat up you know yeah but okay on the
flip side when you don't have much and
you have to show up and look very
presentable and like with nice things
you don't have very many nice things so
again I get it I grew up in that
situation so I wore under 10 times and I
agree with them okay so then um I ended
up asking Santa for these shoes LA Gear
I'm like [ __ ] and Santa usually got me
what I wanted because I would like I
understood so I never felt poor but it
was really sad though in your life my
mom your mom okay yeah um I under I
never felt poor but I understood that my
parents had to work really hard in order
to get this money to use this money to
buy me what I wanted and that like at a
very young age I hated that concept of
my parents working as hard as they did
because I think I really wanted my
parents with me and I'm like but they
can't be with me because I have to
provide so if I ask for Less maybe they
don't have to provide us hard so like
any time and I'm talking for like as
young as I can [ __ ] remember is that
because they've always brought that up
like oh we can't afford that or that
kind of money like where did you get
where did you get the concept of budget
from it wasn't a for they wouldn't say
we can't afford it but they would just
be like oh man that's really expensive
you know so it wasn't like we don't have
the means to do it it was more so like
that thing is just not worth that price
right either worth it or it's just too
expensive you know so it was never like
we can't afford it and that's probably
why I don't I never felt like poor we
were poor right
and I never heard my parents really talk
about like they didn't argue about money
like any of that stuff I never like I
never I I did I never knew if like we
paid the rent late like our water never
got shut off our power never got shut
off like there was always food in the
fridge like everything I ever needed
like all my my basic needs were all
covered and like then some and now a
word from our sponsor better help how
well would you take care of your car if
you had to keep the same one your entire
life
damn I love that question that's how our
brains work so why wouldn't we treat
them that way I love that because we all
know after certain miles we need an oil
check or we need to lift up the hood and
see what's going on in there I wish that
our like bodies would be like you know
our hand would like change a color I
mean I guess it does right when it needs
some help but I wish our brains had like
like a little icon or something that
goes like hey let's check it out
but it doesn't but we should be viewing
it that way so how we care for our minds
affects how we experience life and that
is a hundred percent true so it's
important to invest time and Care into
keeping them healthy and I couldn't
agree with that statement more like it's
been in ingrained in us that every year
we need to get a physical exam right
just to make sure that everything is
oiled up and properly working and you
know we we add more years to our life
than subtract from them and I as far
back as I can remember that's always
something that's been like really
instilled in us but why not our brain
whereas we know through study and
studies and Science and experiments that
our brains can really affect the health
of our body right you know it can really
affect how like the statement says how
we view life so
when I heard that better help exists it
made me so happy to know that we have so
much access to licensed therapists at
our fingertips because some of us live
in areas where we don't have you know
the access to the the the caliber of
therapists that we need some of us might
live in a rural rural area where we
can't just get in our cars and leave or
we might just be you know in a place
where we don't have the right support so
it's really dope that better help exists
because
betterhelp is an online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
only therapy sessions so
um you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't feel comfortable
doing that it's much more than
affordable
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy
um you can be matched with the therapist
in under 48 Hours okay and for everyone
listening right now we are hooking you
guys up with 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
get close that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash get close you know one
of my biggest arguments I've ever had
was with my aunt the same author hooked
me up with the LA Gear in the back seat
of a car over something like that like
what
sorry for all we're doing maybe going on
a hike as a family or something and I
remember I was thirsty and I was like
hey can we get a Coke and then my mom's
like sure I'm like can we go to 7-Eleven
and then my aunt's like no we can't like
you know how expensive the coke is at
7-Eleven
it's a dollar
for a whole for one cup
she goes we can go to Ralph's right now
and buy Six you know like how it's like
a pack of six I know but I'm thirsty
right now there's seven right there and
then she was like no we're not gonna
waste money like that and we got into
one big house oh man probably like seven
or eight and I was like I was like
you're gonna let a
kid a thirsty kid
get even more thirsty
um you're not gonna take care of me she
goes yeah you can suck it the [ __ ] up
for a little bit so we can get something
that's more worth the price
and uh what was crazy was I think when I
was a kid I couldn't articulate it
but I think what I really wanted was
just
um
to experience what people did on TV
uh like I would just see like the white
kids the white kids go to 7-Eleven or
even my friends right they got to do the
thing they got to go and like go to
7-Eleven and buy a drink in the
Styrofoam cup and drink it or they got
to buy the one bag of chips rather than
like if my mom were to buy chips it
would be
this and then oh you want to take some
to school
zip lock back and you had Ziploc bags we
didn't have this we had the folder yeah
yeah the Ziploc is for Ballers I don't
know the foldable kind of you tuck it
over and you tuck it back she would get
those bags yeah and then so like I never
got the
experience but you know when you're a
kid you don't know that what about the
experience you're just like my [ __ ] is
always and even [ __ ] ghetto rappers I
want to have like an actual I want to
get the bag that says 99 cents on it
yeah that one and even so remember that
feeling because I know I'm gonna go
through that with taika because what
we're trying to instill is patience
right like you don't want to follow the
herd like you are like like budgeting
the value of a dollar right yeah as a
parent that's what we're trying to
instill in these kids but as a kid
you're just like I don't give a [ __ ]
like I'm just trying to experience the
kid you know that I see on TV yeah
um so I'm sure I'm probably gonna do
something like that to taika because I'm
trying to elevate him to be above the
the normal standard yeah so that's I'm
like remember this feeling because I
might be that parent I'm trying not to
be but I might be the parent that's like
no no you can wait it's okay and then
this way the whole family can benefit
from it where he's probably gonna be
like [ __ ] I can't articulate it but I
just want to experience
X yeah I want to experience what I see
over there yeah yeah and then but as an
adult mind now you're going who cares
that's all fake marketing they're that's
all [ __ ] consumerism that's what they
want you to do that's how they're
manipulating a kid because that they
want the kid to ask for it to let the
parents go back you know what I mean
yeah yeah because I would always see all
the kids on the street like rollerblade
to the donut shop local down the street
and everyone has the crushed ice and
they're just sitting on the curb
drinking it through a straw I'm like one
we don't have straws at home I'm like
that's like white people stuff and then
I'm like and if I wanted a drink it's
because I brought it from home so I have
like a Capri Sun but it's yeah Capri Sun
yes but it's like it's not the the thing
you know I want to do the thing that
everyone's doing yeah yeah yeah so I
remember um going back to my Ellie gear
story
asking Santa for them and I was like oh
that's a big ask because it's not
Payless because like you I would also
wear Payless and I [ __ ] hated wearing
Payless because probably you didn't have
this issue but I would play a lot and my
feet would sweat and like it's just
incubating in this cheap ass leather
that's Payless my feet would stank it
was stank ass feet you know you can't
relate uh no because the Payless shoes I
got they were kind of like knockoff
Chucks uh which is funny because Chuck's
at that time were cheap anyways they
were they were like 20 bucks but um
so we had my mom would just buy me um
these knockoff Chucks that I liked
because they're the closest looking to
my kung fu shoes uh oh and you like this
idea flyer type yeah I really liked them
because I felt like I could like sweep
people if I needed to
always ready for combat yeah yeah okay
so then it's uh it's Christmas morning I
open up my presents because I was
fortunate enough to get a few presents
my mom would do everything she possibly
could and that's how I was going oh I
broke my heart because I knew where it
was coming from to make it as much of a
white Christmas as possible we didn't
just get one present each like it wasn't
a sad Christmas it was like a [ __ ]
really cool Christmas like we all had
four kids we all at least had three
different presents wow yeah yeah my mom
was red
um yeah so it's Christmas morning
um opened up my presents I'm like [ __ ] I
didn't get my [ __ ] LA Gear and then
she goes no but you did like she goes to
the closet and I was like what and she
pulls out this present I open it up but
they're like knock off La gears and I
was like these are not the same thing
these are Vegas gears
what are these yeah and I'm [ __ ]
heartbroken now because I'm like oh man
she did her best and I was like these
are not it I'm like no you got the wrong
ones spoiled ass kid you know I'm like
no you got the wrong ones mom she says
no this is this these are the same ones
I'm like they're not L.A gears look and
I'm all like it doesn't say la gear on
the shoes oh yeah so I I I do I can't
broke your mom's heart I'm sure I'm sure
it broke her heart but I'm sure she was
pissed you know yeah like do you know
what [ __ ] Hoops I [ __ ] jump to
afford this [ __ ] you know what I'm going
these are not the right ones it's like
you ungrateful piece of trash yeah yeah
yeah yeah
but I can totally relate to like that
belonging because I'm like it doesn't
say Ellie gear on it you know what's
crazy is
um
I would get [ __ ] up
uh in my brain like psychologically
um not that my mom's like a master of
psychological warfare but her actions
are
you know so like what is she getting a
[ __ ] a lima bean and [ __ ] and cutting
it like really really tiny and then just
kind of serving it to you like this is
all we can do no like so um
you know like the street that I grew up
on I always talk about how like it's
like four or five best friends all
living on that street right all
different ethnicities Indian half white
half Chinese Korean guy Filipino family
and we were active like on that street
we all did the same Hobbies which is why
I like you're like damn like you know
when we first started dating you're like
dude you could do everything you could
ride a bike pretty good skateboard like
play hockey basketball and it's because
our street was just active so we all
played everything we played baseball on
our front yard like we all played like
everything right and then so when you
play everything you get gear for
everything oh and then when you get gear
for everything and you're in that age of
belonging now the minute there's a one
guy with something legit that's the
standard so everyone has to get the
legit stuff right so
um I had my cheap ass Toys R Us bike no
one that ever buys a legit bike is gonna
get from Toys R Us because they're only
like the toy brand yeah you know and so
when I found out about like GT and Dino
the whole street everyone got GT Dino or
like that level right and then um you
would start hearing like oh man and then
we would talk about some other kid from
down the street oh that kid got a red
line and so red line is at that time
would be like the Ferrari of bikes you
know it's like oh [ __ ] everyone has GT
Dyno but then that one is Redline so
finally
when uh it didn't really matter anymore
like maybe when I'm like 10 or 11 my mom
gonna take me to finally buy like a
legit BMX bike and then we go to I go we
can't be going to Toys R Us we all know
those are shitty bikes we got to go to a
bike store we go to the bike store and I
see
a red line I go oh I'm like that's the
one that's the coveted one that everyone
talks about I want that one right how
much did they go for oh man at that time
or what's the equivalent to now well I
don't know about that time it was like
200 bucks
yeah so my mom buys it no what yeah she
buys it from me she goes okay that
doesn't make any sense to her pattern so
she goes you want this one we'll get it
for you the minute we take it home here
are all the contingencies you got to do
this this this this this this right
obviously there are things that I cannot
do like pay attention in school and get
good grades so it ends up being chained
to the inside of the garage she just
spent 500 or 200 yeah and it's just
chained there and I'm like telling the
kids bro I got a red line they're like
no you don't bring it out the thing is I
can't bring it out but I got one the
player has got one right and then
they're like nah we don't believe you
and then you didn't bring them over I
would I'd bring them over check it out
they're like well open it what are you
doing I'm like that's the thing that's
not how it works around here it's locked
up right so there'd be that and then
what torture is your mom doing to you
and then we got into street hockey right
or uh aggressive of skating do you know
what aggressive skating is yeah so when
like the first like uh yeah the skate
and inline skating when like the whole X
Games came into play it was two really
big movements you have the guys that
would like grind down rails and stuff on
inline skates and then there's dudes
that did it with skateboards right
um
and it's all our whole street got into
inline skating and uh the brand to get
was Rosie's right and then so everyone
was getting roasties or whatever and uh
I had my Toys R Us brand some [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] but I would still try to
keep up and play or whatever finally
when uh no one really cared about it
that much anymore and I'd finally beg
baby my mom's all right fine I'll take
you to go get some actual inline skates
and then once again I would see okay
Rosie's Bros and then there's the one at
the end that is like the coveted one in
like the glass case I'm like I want that
one and my mom would be like dope did
you get it for me right and then once
again contingency contingency
contingency so it's locked up
and finally those things would be
released to me when no one gives a [ __ ]
anymore so once you get into High School
my like all the cool kids if if you're a
cool kid you're getting driven by older
kids right or your older sibling is
taking you no one's really riding their
bike to high school but now I have a red
line which is sick but now in this new
world no one gives a [ __ ] because
everyone's driving so I'm driving my
sick ass [ __ ] red line to school but
I don't get 30 years old but I don't get
the [ __ ] props and it's years old I
have my sick ass rollerblades that no
one gives a [ __ ] because it I didn't
have it when it mattered it's like a 70
year old getting a yellow Corvette yeah
you know it's like you're gonna die so
you don't even need that you know it's
like that it's like it's cool to have
your like Porsche when you're like I
don't know early 30s like a stock broker
then you could live that wolf on Wall
Street life not when you're 90. yeah
yeah and then so I would get like the
psychological warfare of like did I have
it yeah technically but did it have the
impact in the belonging that I was
supposed to have yeah no yeah yeah
because she's treating you like an adult
like when you go to do your job you get
paid
yeah and it's like well you're just like
uh but that's not how it's working in my
head because I'm a [ __ ] troubled kid
and you don't understand me yeah and
then so I'm not even gonna get it yeah
so I the whole it's like that's that was
like that's why to me in my mind it was
psychological I received it as
psychological welfare I know she didn't
mean it like that but I received it like
that because the things that I was
insecure about
I had
but
the timing of it yeah was off so the
feeling of being ashamed I also had
while I had the option because you're
staring at it yeah that's horrible yeah
that's horrible yeah that's just it was
just bad parenting
for your style of uh kid yeah because I
honestly I wouldn't have bought it for
you or I I mean I I don't know if I I
believe in like allowance like you do
this like if it's house [ __ ] I'm like
now am I gonna pay you for contributing
to the family
no it's more like it's just school stuff
yeah yeah no I'm saying me right like
um I don't know if I would
if it's school stuff then it needs to be
school related stuff that I'm punishing
you for right like like I don't know I
just don't think that the punishment was
fitting the crime I see yeah that's that
was such a breath of fresh air when I
moved in with my dad when I was like 15
16. yeah because uh when I moved in
there
my dad's like okay you have her license
you need to have a car and I was like
what the [ __ ] I'm like you're like that
makes sense I'm like I get to have
something because I just exist because
I'm supposed to have it versus I don't
need to like
Bam Bam Bam Bam do like these 20 things
like get a 4.0 and [ __ ] be in the
math club or [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ]
or know how to like write my name in
Chinese like or you know just some all
the crazy ass things on my like my mom
wanted me to do my dad's like no you're
16 like you need to be independent like
I think you need to have a car and you
should have a cell phone and I was like
I think you're right Ed that's crazy
that's I think you're right and then he
was like but the level of it I think
that's up to you you know he goes like
this is what I can afford and he's like
I can give you uh three grand
you can go buy whatever car you want
or if you want to go work and add on top
of that you can get whatever car you
know or if you actually do get the 4.0
she's like I'm your mom's rich or she
would say my mom's Rich compared to my
dad but my mom's not rich at all yeah
yeah but uh because my dad's a car
dealer my mom actually has like an
actual nine to five yeah so from my
dad's point of view he's like your mom's
Rich so I'm sure if you get a 4.0 uh
she'll buy you whatever car you want
yeah and then it was just crazy to hear
like some logical sense like I'm
supposed to get this just because of
this you know so yeah my dad uh ended up
uh helping me by
um
off of uh my aunt yeah it's like a Camry
oh okay but now I have wheels yeah yeah
yeah yeah
and that's 16 dude yeah so I have wheels
and then so that way I can take myself
to school if I need to or you know or go
to wrestling practice whatever and I got
a cell phone so I can call him he can
call me
just so he's like that's what he's like
everyone has a cell phone why wouldn't
you have one
damn yeah so [ __ ] extreme it was so
and then that to me mattered because I'm
like cool I don't have the best car I
don't got some of the sick ass rice
rockets that maybe some of the other
kids have more money have
but I'm in the club so if people go hey
we should go like go to whatever movies
I'm like okay we'll meet you guys there
I don't have to go can someone pick me
up
you know I mean there's nothing wrong
with that there's nothing wrong with
that either but yeah dude I [ __ ] just
wanted to [ __ ] catch the bus that's
how bad I wanted to like be with other
people I'm like don't drive me around
everywhere it's just so goddamn
embarrassing I want to be in the club
let me can I just catch the bus I'll pay
for it myself can I just catch the bus
she's like [ __ ] no you cannot
yeah so lucky you had a [ __ ] car at
16 dude yeah that's amazing yeah that's
pretty cool yeah
um so okay so yeah I think most of my
insecurities came from like the physical
another one was I wanted to dress myself
and my mom's like you cannot be shopping
at the youth section you have to be
shopping in the little girls section I'm
like what
why why
I want to be a [ __ ] I'm a woman now
Mom I wear a bra she's like you're not
going in the [ __ ] teen section damn
yeah what's funny is too is a teen
section is probably like baby tea with
like two sunflowers too yeah exactly
it's not it's not even like hoochie
where you know for her it was
it's just more like shaped a little
that's the Hoochie that's so it needed
to be loose fitting yeah they needed to
be loose
that's crazy there was that and then
like obviously no makeup I couldn't cut
my hair
um so don't even think about dyeing your
hair so no makeup no cutting the hair
couldn't shave my legs until high school
until High School yeah until High School
God damn you're a wild animal yeah why
not so you need more shorts then I would
never want to wear shorts I would see
all the girls in my class and they were
wearing short shorts and I'm like
you can't so I had the palest legs ever
you'll see you'll see the first time I
went to Hawaii I was like maybe in
eighth grade yeah seventh eighth grade
and I'm just wearing [ __ ] pants the
entire time Pat's in Hawaii exactly yes
oh my hands in [ __ ] Hawaii
yeah
you must be sweating through those jeans
yeah but I'm about to show my [ __ ]
hairy legs hairy ass what's wrong with
the uh shaving your legs it's just too
it's a woman thing so let's say you
secretly did it in the shower what would
happen she would [ __ ] chew your ass
out I guess so I think she would just I
would be in trouble I didn't even want
to test it I was scared wow what she she
made it like explicit like you better
not shave your [ __ ] legs yeah yeah
yeah what about your older sister wasn't
she shaving her legs yeah but she's 15
years older than me dude oh no she
wasn't shaving them at my age if that's
what you mean so she's like 28 or
something yeah she's already old oh damn
yeah she's already past her due date and
she would never tell like her mom like
she needs to shave her life she's 13. no
I don't I mean not that I can recall
yeah so there was that so I think a lot
of it so maybe I was like really focused
I don't know I really don't know maybe I
just liked beauty or [ __ ] I have no
idea but yeah a lot of it revolved
around that at least in the beginning it
was just like my appearance so I
couldn't pluck my eyebrows either
obviously yeah some of those pictures up
there you got some bushy eyebrows yep
I mean they're not that bad now that I
look at it but in that time you know
when everyone else had especially the
90s like everyone had like the [ __ ]
little tititas like the little [ __ ]
little lines you know yeah
um so for sure mine were bushy but once
High School came I was like [ __ ] all
that [ __ ] how are you able to do that
what Break Free in high school
um I mean you just start rebelling you
know what I mean like it started off
with me just saving my clothes from when
I was younger and now it fits like
Tighter and smaller oh you know like I
would just start making my own clothes
yeah dang yeah and then I mean I could
shave and I could do all that stuff and
um were you ever insecure about your
height no I didn't even realize I was
tall
because I because I mean like if you're
tall in junior high then automatically
you're the giraffe you know everyone's
gonna call you that [ __ ] no I didn't get
any of that wow
the high school like anything that's I
feel like at least from the guys world
like from seven to I don't know maybe
even 15 even even everyone is just
trying to belong yeah anyone that's not
belonging whether you're too tall Too
Short too fat too skinny too whatever
yeah you're getting called out for all
of that no I didn't feel it until I was
probably in high school until guys were
like wow you're tall and I was like what
because of my one of my best friends was
also my height we look like sisters so I
was just like Oh you mean you're short
like we are good yeah yeah I didn't even
realize like that wasn't a thing
yes I wasn't insecure about that
um I never was like the pretty girl in
school you know like I wasn't like the
popular girl so I was definitely
insecure about my looks have you ever uh
looked up what what the pretty girls up
to um
I I did in high school or early college
yeah I wanted to go back to uh
the girl
that literally all the guys had a crush
on and in the locker room everyone was
always talking about Sally about Sally
Sally this Sally did Sally that and then
uh so I think in in I think Myspace or
Facebook days you know like that's when
you're like oh [ __ ] I can connect with
the world yeah I was like I wonder what
Sally's up to I looked her up like oh
[ __ ] God she peeked in high school huh
damn no she peaked when she was in
junior high oh
[ __ ] God damn that's [ __ ] crazy
yeah isn't that crazy yeah it's crazy
yeah so I'm glad I didn't I didn't peak
in high school or Junior High I was
Falcon busted and she was with the dude
that in high school we saw we swore the
[ __ ] god or in junior high and High
School
we swore the [ __ ] god this guy was
gay because he's [ __ ] flamboyant as
[ __ ] so um
in junior high for a talent show he's
saying Whitney Houston and his fingers
and wrist is always pointing like this
and then he was the first guy ever to be
on the Cerritos High School cheerleading
team
and he was the first guy ever and they
made a space for him to be on there
and then he got with the girl from
Junior High and we all thought he was
gay isn't that crazy yeah passing
judgment yeah we're like what the [ __ ]
we could have sworn he was gay what the
[ __ ] is going on yeah yeah yeah no I had
I had a ton of insecurities but I think
it was more so like man like I just
wasn't I just wasn't acute I was just
busted ass Geo really yeah dude I was
not cute at all the first time I ever
laid eyes on you I thought you were so
pretty thank you but yeah that that's
not that wasn't the word around school
at least that I knew of then when they
just slowly start getting more pretty
then maybe in college I don't know but
it was it wasn't until I graduated high
school so in the high school you're
busted still like your face still needed
to be to be rearranged I thought so it
still wasn't arranging in the right
order the guys weren't like [ __ ]
knocking down my door to like date me
how do you know
nobody told me they didn't tell me until
after high school that they had a crush
on you yeah that's when all the
confessions started happening I was like
why didn't you I [ __ ] liked you too
hello it's already too late because I'm
like Ugh
I've moved on to the college boys yeah
yeah dang
dang yeah I wasn't I wasn't like the
they weren't like oh Geo's Ohio
[ __ ] Geo maybe it was because you had
an attitude problem like you still do so
it's hard for Peter like people to show
their their affections I did always for
as far back as I can remember I was
always the like oh you're too into
dating or like yeah that was that was
that was the line for GEOS because
intimidating it does also mean probably
good looking
I didn't take it like that if you
probably were good looking and
judgmental at the same time I think it
was probably I was tall and judgmental
and like and resting [ __ ] face probably
an attitude problem bro [ __ ] I know
this [ __ ] guy man do you hear us
arguing
well why can you do it I'm like well
what do you mean why I can do it because
I'm an adult he's like yeah but it
doesn't like he's like questioning my
[ __ ] logic and I'm like nah dude it
doesn't work like that and I really
can't explain it
he does have an attitude problem man
that's all your mom right there yeah
well whatever anyway what about now do
you have any security insecurities now
now it's more so
um it's not it has nothing to do with
like the physical stuff
it's more so more of my intellect oh wow
what about before getting there were
there any materialistic things at all
before getting wet before getting there
were there any materialistic things at
all
oh really yeah I have a little bit like
what
So like
um I didn't realize I was in it
um when you're in it because you know
how like you're just your brain does its
thing where it always wants to make you
the good guy right so you're always
justifying things
but I do think uh during that phase of
like when me and Joe bought Rolexes and
we bought super nice cars I do think I
was trying to live up to the YouTuber
look what's the YouTuber look especially
at that time so at that time um I think
you would see like almost any YouTuber
that made it or like both because I
think YouTuber the cool thing about
being a YouTuber it's almost you kind of
made it as like not only a content
creator but also entrepreneur right like
not only did you get good views you knew
how to monetize off of it right so the
people that were able to do that they
generally had nice things and I think it
might have even started started with
like uh like mystery Guitar Man you know
oh my God remember like like those guys
like OG right like you would have that
and then you would go to like uh VidCon
or whatever and you would see people
with like oh [ __ ] I'm like because I've
been into watches
since I first watched James Bond you
know so I recognize people oh [ __ ] that
guy's a Submariner like as a Rollie you
know and then then like Ryan Higa you
know he got a Lotus and then so he would
just start to see like oh [ __ ] and then
I think for uh me personally I can't
speak for Joe for me personally I think
we've been
like grinding so hard with YouTube yeah
and we're in the same rooms and we're
performing at the same shows and we're
big and we're in Australia and we're
doing all those things
um but I also think there's like a check
box or box that has never been checked
where it's like I want I want to stunt a
little bit too like a stunt to to like
um obviously I still like sports cars
I've always liked stick but also there's
a thing of like I want to be able to
like live the YouTuber life yeah so like
I had I definitely had that and I think
it was an insecurity that was maybe so
strong yeah that I Justified it as oh I
need to get this for this and this for
this oh I'm not insecure uh but then I
think it was maybe or maybe even
insecure towards myself that I needed to
prove to myself that I can get those
things yeah you know but did you ever
even have that in between
not really no yeah because as you were
doing that I wasn't like oh yeah I gotta
live up to that too it was more so like
I've always liked nice things I just
couldn't afford it and then as soon as I
can afford it I'm like sick but then
once I got it like remember the first
time I could afford like an LV purse on
my own I'm like I have to get this
because it's like a rite of passage yeah
and now thinking about that could
probably be an insecurity right it might
have been insecurity for yourself
because it wasn't like I got to show the
world nobody yeah nobody has any but for
me it was like I I [ __ ] achieved this
[ __ ] right looking at it now it's like
you what you [ __ ] can spend money and
not save it the right way yeah yeah um
so like I bought it and once I bought it
I was like oh it's like that's it like
that feeling is gone within like seconds
you know like I I paid for it I now it's
mine and I'm like oh that's it so that's
when I was just like I'm not really into
like material things like that like I'm
not into labels I'm not into any of that
[ __ ]
um
it's more so like okay the quality of it
is really good so when I when I got like
let's say another LV purse which is
[ __ ] funny
um I didn't get it I didn't get it now
with for the same reason it wasn't like
oh because I want to floss or because
like now I've made it or whatever it was
more so like well this is a really good
quality bag and even the bag that I got
it is really good quality um yeah the
bag that I got has like it's so muted
that like it's just a black purse even
the LV logo is black because I'm just
like I'm not trying to do it to stunt
yeah you're not trying to get the crazy
print one yeah I'm not trying to show
the person across the room that like oh
[ __ ] I'm wearing LV it's just like this
is a [ __ ] quality purse and I'm
paying for the quality or whatever
um and I just it's just a black purse
yeah even for me
um my LV wallet remember the one that I
bought for myself and Joe at the same
time yeah that I used to change wallets
every year did you remember that yeah
because I would just wear it out
and this wallet I think I've had for
over five years brand new and it looks
brand [ __ ] new and you can't even
tell that it's LV because I also didn't
want to stunt or whatever yeah it was
just they make really good stuff yeah so
like uh when I did encounter more money
um I didn't care for any of that I'm
just like I just like cool [ __ ] like we
always laugh about this but it's like
what do you want from here and I'm like
oh that one's tight they're like yeah
that's the most expensive one I'm like
[ __ ] you know like I'm not doing it I'm
not going which one's the most expensive
one give me that I'm just like I like
quality [ __ ] and quality [ __ ] comes with
the price tag yeah even when we're like
picking trims to like for our house yeah
you're like oh which one of the counters
like I like that counter like well that
one is the oh [ __ ] what about uh I like
those cabinets though that one is
actually like God damn it so
um I just like quality but I'm not going
out of my way to get the most expensive
things so that people think that I'm
either balling or that I'm like with
them or whatever you know yeah like even
this house feels like too much of a
stunt for me oh I'm just like all right
[ __ ] tone it the [ __ ] down you know you
know what I actually think I was really
insecure actually with like the Porsche
and the rolling and stuff like that
because now that I'm thinking about it
and also kind of time like the whole
storyline together I was like
I don't think I ever felt like I got the
thing in the right time to be in the
tribe at the right time still no no no
but like I never get into that no I
never did right yeah yeah prior to that
I never did yeah where I always got it
in the wrong time or whatever and so I
think like I was finally in control uh
uh because I think in my mind I'm
actually pretty financially intelligent
because of the my the way my mom raised
me right like I started when I was a kid
we rented the rooms out and
um and then my mom was able to get
another house and we rent that out and
I've helped my mom rent so I like in in
the rental game I've actually been in
the rental game for like 30 years yeah
you know like seeing just like the small
interactions so I think in terms of like
holding off what you want so that you
can let money build over time and like
that whole like compounding concept it's
not something that I had to learn yeah
it was something I understood yeah so
the minute I was gonna go buy the Rolex
um I think I had a sense of guilt like
oh this is not the right move
um but the feeling of wanting to belong
was bigger wow I'm getting it you know I
need to get it and the same thing with
even like the Porsche I'm like dude this
car payment is like 1300 bucks a month
I'm like if I could put that into stocks
or I could buy a house yeah you know we
didn't I didn't even buy a house yet and
I was like I could that's that's well
that wasn't part of the financial plan
either yes but still I think like
I think I just wanted to belong got it
you know so I think like once I belong
and I realized belonging doesn't mean
anything it doesn't and then I think
belonging to whom yeah exactly yeah and
then I was like this doesn't even matter
and then I think it finally like I was
going through the whole like
yeah like my whole metamorphosis
I think I fully fully understood was
when I got my RS7 the Audi right that's
technically like a super car no I was
like my dad's super car and
um my car was so cool yeah I decked it
out with the exhaust
rims custom paint calipers chipped it uh
lowered it tuned it and it was like I
don't know 600 700 horses and as soon as
I turned that beast on like you heard
the whole
own like it sounds like a Supercar right
my super dad car
and uh
but I just didn't drive it that much
yeah you didn't yeah and then drove your
truck yeah and then I was like looking
at I was like I'm like it's cool to like
nice things I'm not hating on that like
if you like nice things go get nice
things you know but I think that's the
reason why ultimately what you're trying
to do regardless if you're getting is
nice or not nice or whatever you're
trying to bring happiness and joy into
your life yeah and then when I looked at
my like fifty thousand dollar
Silverado
or I looked at my like a hundred and
thirty thousand or hundred fifty
thousand dollar Audi I was like man they
both bring equal Joy
but this one I could drive every day
especially in the potholes of La yeah
and then the other one I already popped
my tire twice and because the tires are
so thin you know and then I'm like
that's when I was like I got it
I sold it and I thought I would leave a
little void in my heart but it did it
yeah so I was like oh [ __ ]
I think I'm over that whole thing yeah
same so now I'm like I don't even feel
like I need I feel like I've I've joined
the club
and now I'm like respectfully declining
the membership yeah but it was it was
cool to I think do that for myself yeah
I think so I think I needed to do that a
lot of people need to do that because I
never had it when I was a kid and then
um I just I think I just needed to get
through yeah I definitely had my my
version of that for sure
um but for me it was more so like uh
getting tattoos chopping off my hair
like all the things that I always wanted
to do that I'm like it's not that big of
a [ __ ] deal mom yeah dad you know
what I mean then I'm just like I'm
[ __ ] doing it I'm everything I
couldn't do or all the [ __ ] voids
that I thought I had I'm [ __ ] going
Balls to the [ __ ] walls I think
most people what they're really chasing
as an adult is just fixing all the
traumas as a kid yeah I think so too
yeah like you know like a lot of the
dudes that we know that love shoes like
even like David said right I can only
buy all these J's yeah because I didn't
really have them yeah and then but I
don't wear nothing of them I just wear
these same go-to pairs yeah for the most
part but then there's also people that
are just genuine collectors of it they
love the storyline different yeah yeah
that is a difference so to me I'm like
if that brings you that level of
Happiness yeah because your collector
that's different yeah but I think I
wasn't feeling the happiness bucket I
was feeling the insecurity bucket yeah
yeah I've had that too I think now is
more so um like I was saying like it's
more so having to do with just me as a
person like I just want to be a good
person I want to be a smart person not
that I think I'm dumb but like there's
so much for me to learn you know like I
want to gain more wisdom like I do want
to like invest like I want to set up my
family's families family type stuff
um yeah I don't care about
flexing or flossing or like that's never
really been my thing
so like yeah the insecurities back then
were more so physical and like
um not having things and kind of like
you like the belonging yeah whereas now
it's more so of like I just want to make
sure I sound not stupid
you know like I like I can contribute
some meaning into like the room that I'm
in or the people that I'm around like I
can like add some value to that like I
think I'm more insecure about adding
value than not yeah
yeah
damn good topic dude
this CUNY did you just discover that
like in this conversation yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah that I was like oh [ __ ] I think I
wasn't secure that I didn't know because
it's also a huge blend right because
it's because I am a true hobbyist yeah
you know what I mean so it's not like
one of those guys like dude what is that
did you do you have a like an Audi and
they're like yeah it's like oh what are
the specs it's just a car I don't know
you know like I I know everything about
the Audi I knew everything about the
Porsche yeah you know so it's like like
if people go oh it's Porsche you have
like oh it's the 991 like I actually
know that the model for that year yeah
you know and then like oh yeah
afterwards came the 996 or whatever like
I know I know about those things see
even with the roll the rolly because I'm
a hobbyist I really am into those things
right
um so it wasn't just like when someone
goes like oh like why does your rolly
have like two second hands I don't know
it's part of design it's really cool
yeah yeah it's like I know why it is you
know this is the aviator's watch So like
um I think because of that and because
my hobbyist side was so strong yeah you
just I didn't realize that I think it it
also came out of insecurity yeah well
damn super bad look at that [ __ ]
breakthroughs left and right for you
today yeah alrighty bikini thank you so
much for sharing that I think it's so
much for tuning in we'll catch you next
week